desde 2001 los talibanes se escondieron
en las montañas afganistán es el octavo
país más montañoso del mundo se
refugiaron en pakistán con quien
comparten 2.600 kilómetros de frontera y
poco a poco fueron controlando las zonas
rurales abandonadas por eeuu y sus
aliados en detrimento de los centros
urbanos el motivo la dificultad de
controlar un país de más de 650 mil
kilómetros cuadrados y 38 millones de
habitantes desde el 14 de abril cuando
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden ordenó la retirada de tropas el
talibán pasó de controlar 73 distritos
de 450 a más de la mitad a día de hoy
desde allí rodearon las capitales de
provincia y en la última semana han
capturado un total de 18 entre las que
se encuentran kandahar y herat segunda y
tercera ciudad respectivamente
antes de eso controlaron pasos
fronterizos en uzbekistán tayikistán y
especialmente en pakistán también las
carreteras este control les permitió un
mayor dominio de la distribución de
actividades como la minería y el
narcotráfico de hecho afganistán es el
mayor productor de opio del mundo de
donde resulta la heroína el país tiene
224 mil hectáreas de cultivos 115 mil
están en el suroeste en las provincias
de helmand y kandahar recién capturadas
en 2020 la producción habría reportado
350 millones de dólares dinero que
contrasta con los datos de la ciudadanía
el 54,4 por ciento vive en la pobreza y
solo un 43% de la población está
alfabetizada los últimos meses han
dejado más de 389 mil desplazados con
2,6 millones de refugiados en 2020 un
conflicto en el que parece que el más de
billón de dólares invertidos por eeuu y
los más de 3.500 muertos producto de una
guerra de dos décadas no han servido
para derrotar al talibán